la bataille contre locaux vides 19
haoran est déjà mise en scène au théâtre
comme si c'était déjà un lointain
souvenir
moins d'un an après le début de la
pandémie les médecins et infirmières
sont devenus des héros et orane un
modèle pour les autorités chinoises les
participants ont combattu l'épidémie en
première ligne et donc dans cette pièce
ils expriment leurs vrais sentiments la
circulation épidémique mais aussi la
situation des hôpitaux dans les régions
concernées notamment en auvergne
rhône-alpes et bourgogne franche comté
ne nous permettent pas d'envisager une
ouverture pour la période de noël
bonjour docteur vestaires toujours
docteur à chaud est-ce que vous avez
tous nous aider sur la semaine cette
semaine il sera loisible à chacun
chacune et à tous de se rendre dans ces
stations pour profiter de l'air pur de
nos belles montagnes des commerces hors
bars et restaurants qui seront couverts
simplement toutes les remontées
mécaniques et des équipements collectifs
seront fermés au public
c'est un premier ministre c'est une
caricature à reims le premier ministre
est venu constater en personne les
vertus du shampouine âge et du balayage
j'imagine que vous attendiez avec
impatience
les catholiques eux regrette que le
gouvernement n'ait pas accédé à leur
demande ils souhaitaient que la jauge
des 30 personnes maximum lors des messes
soit élargi ce ne sera pas le cas du
coup les évêques de france ont engagé un
recours au conseil d'état en référé et
aujourd'hui certains ont même décidé de
passer outre ces règles
et nous
wade
à rennes le culte de ce soir était par
exemple ouvert à tous et les fidèles
plus nombreux 200 personnes exactement
ont participé à l'office
c'était vraiment très très important
pour moi de venir parce que je suis
chrétienne et on vit de la messe et si
on va pas là mais sont épanouis
l'eucharistie c'est toute notre vie donc
c'est essentiel pour nous j'ai été mis à
rude épreuve très clairement mais on a
redressé la pente
en effet il a et 2,9 des employés pour
accueillir les visiteurs
après un mois de fermeture la
responsable des ventes et rassurer les
clients sont de retour dix minutes
d'applaudissements nourris à la surprise
dès qu'ils mettent plutôt heureuse de la
réouverture des magasins jean ping
vraiment attendu oui beaucoup pour me
oui beaucoup avec impatience on sort de
prison
on sort de prison geffray sur l'effort
elle est entièrement fausse d'ailleurs
quand on doit remplir une attestation
pour venir ici
c'est vrai vous aussi l'atout en plus
ils nous travaillons ministre de
l'intérieur ça on est contrôlé quand
même leurs amis on a un masque peut pas
croire de valeurs là ça m'amuserait j'ai
été contrôlé à plusieurs reprises la
preuve justement devant luxembourg et
récemment sert vraiment à rien d'être
maîtrisé est ce que nous aurons assez de
vaccins en france dans les jours qui
viennent
tout est fait pour que nous en ayons
asus était fait pour les masses tout
était fait pour tous c'est quelque chose
de très compliqué que cette logistique
de la vaccination
parce que les vaccins vont arriver par
par paquet d'abord un débat que ça
datant dé mais je suis policier vers en
ondes et larusso larusso celle truvia
luc alphand sous la manche ottawa faire
les malins
s'élever tellement une trouve fort el
anka mire ça s'appelle les hémorroïdes
nom déposé cette question là cette
pharmacienne ans ministre de la santé
quand martyrs de vaccins j'ai cru
comprendre que j'étais spécialistes en
matière de commandes en tout cas vous
vous êtes assez présents n'ont pas
pervers plein vous avez choisi le ticket
de métro comme moi vous aider pourquoi
pas pourquoi pas moi vois pas pourquoi
pas mais on n'est point l'appareil à
chacun son ticket la semaine a été
marquée évidemment par les images du
passage à tabac de ce producteur de rap
et de hip hop
michel est clair alors des images qui
auraient évidemment choqué au point que
monsieur darmanin quand même le ministre
de l'intérieur et demandé un rapport
alors gérald darmanin a demandé un
rapport mais on ne sait pas avec qui
cette fois alors mais c'est déjà bien
qu'ils demandent ce que si elle produit
celle ci est bien le jure de notre
mariage nous étions devant le monsieur
le maire et je sais pas ce qui m'a pris
comme tel a fallu signer j'ai signé au
nom de mon ex mari
ça passe à monsieur du coup ça vous
amène une petite ambiance festive
directes censées vous faites venir tous
vos ex mari et ben voilà ça fait
plusieurs grosses salles d'ici ferrat
c'est l'heure des blagues c'est un peu
comme la quincaillerie bah écoutez
gérard la pub vous votre rythme
sexuelles avec votre compagnon c'est
combien alors avec mon compagnon c'est 7
8 fois
quoi par jour oui enfin jours des fois
plus et c'est lui qui veut c'est vous
c'est moi mais je le jeu l'épuisent très
souvent oui
il y à 14 ans britney spears et moi
avons inventé le selphy paris s'il tonne
dans les pas à son coup d'essai puisque
en 2010 est déjà elle avait posté il ya
11 ans aujourd'hui mois et britney avons
inventé le sait le fil et à l'époque le
new york times avait enquêté révélé que
non et conclut que le premiers
autoportraits photographiques connu daté
de 1839 robert cornelius voilà tout le
monde s'est foutu de moi
mais non on est allé me chercher cette
victoire incroyable des recours je me
sens fier de moi fier d'avoir rêvé mais
fier toi dave prowse le dark vador de la
première trilogie de star wars est
décédé à l'âge de 85 ans l'acteur
britannique avait été choisi par son
tour son physique impressionnant à m 98
nature blucas considéré que son accent
ne collait pas avec le rôle et lui avait
attribué une doublure voix
que la force soit avec lui toujours à
commenter son agent